the feminist of the year award goes to
president joe biden who does not simply
believe
that women are as good as men
but who believes that women
can do every single thing that there is
to do
better than any man can do it you know
i've told my daughters granddaughters
from the time
they were old enough to understand what
i was saying
and i mean it there's not a single thing
a man can do that a woman can't do as
well or better
not a single thing not a single thing
there is not women can do better than
men men can never do better than women
and that is why i'm resigning the
presidency
and giving it over to kamala harris or
oh wait no he didn't say that
he didn't say that just more bluster
lies
and false modesty from joe biden i'm
michael moses the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday this was close there's
actually a runner-up but my
my favorite was from lightfire ex who
says people are saying how it's easier
to buy a gun than to vote
but last time i checked dead people
can't buy guns
this is true and it's hard for felons to
buy guns
and it's hard for foreign nationals to
buy guns in the united states
and pretty soon if the democrats get
their way all those people are going to
be able to vote
children gosh the list goes on and on
the runner-up though i couldn't let this
one go
my second favorite comment yesterday is
from uh the shuckmeister
who says war is peace freedom is slavery
shrimp is cereal really profound stuff
that is the depths of of new speak
and doublethink and this orwellian
inversion of our culture that we have
sunk to but there are still some simple
solutions in this culture
like for instance if you are a man
interested in your wellness then you can
check out hymns
for hymns.com is all about men's
wellness need help with ed
hair loss or have a cold interested in
mental health or covid19 home tests
hims is here for you hims connects you
with a licensed medical professional
online
who can prescribe fda approved
prescription medication to treat ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill
but without the expensive price tag no
embarrassing conversations no expensive
appointments
just answer a few questions online about
your medical history
and a provider will confidentially
review if approved
your medication will be shipped directly
to your door in discrete packaging
shipping is free i know guys don't want
to always talk about these kinds of
things but there are really simple
solutions
if you were dealing with this problem
try hymns today by starting out with a
free online
visit go to for hims.com michael
for your free visit that's for hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash
michael prescription products are
subject to medical provider approval and
require an online consultation with a
medical provider
who will determine if your prescription
is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that is for
hymns.com
michael speaking of men and men's
problems
what biden said is just obviously not
true he's saying there's nothing that
men can do that women can't do as well
or better
than men chopping wood
men do that better than women writing
love songs
men do that better for women than women
playing tennis that would be a good
example
if you can always read about the great
great battle of the sexes between
carsten brosh
and the williams sisters coursed in
brush before he was about to play
the williams sisters in a back-to-back
tournament in tennis he went out smoked
a bunch of cigarettes drank some
brewskis played a round of golf
and then then beat the women because men
men are physically stronger than women
spatial reasoning would be another
another example where men would seem
generally speaking to have an edge
also even if you're not willing to grant
any of that
in your you think karsten brush had some
unfair advantage or something the
cigarettes gave him power
if what biden says were true
and even if it weren't true but joe
biden believed it were true that that
women can do anything better than men or
at least as well
he wouldn't have run for president in
2020 or he would resign now
joe biden knew that a bunch of women
were going to run for president in 2020
and he chose to run anyway but there's
nothing
that a man can do that a woman can't do
as well or better
so the minute you know look if it were
just men running i could see why joe
biden would run
but if women are going to run well then
you know they're going to do as good a
job
if not a better job than you are doing
so he would have not
run he is the male president right now
he has a female vice president
so he would resign wouldn't he because
or he's just so selfish that he doesn't
want us to have the best president we
possibly can
or he doesn't believe that he obviously
doesn't believe that and it's just
false modesty false modesty is a big
problem in our culture
we we talk so much about pride how
everyone just thinks like i deserve this
and i'm wonderful and i
i'm me me and everyone needs to serve my
whims and everything right that's true
that pervades the culture
we have whole months now dedicated to
pride right not even not even just the
narrow sort of sexual
pride questions but like all sorts of
pride
so that's a big problem false modesty
is just the flip side of that false
modesty
is just another form of pride
true humility does away with false
modesty but false modesty is that sort
of thing you know
someone will say oh i really enjoyed
something that you wrote or something
that you didn't you say oh
no it wasn't really good stop go on
hmm go no no what do you know i don't
agree with that
tell me more you know that's that's uh
false modesty and
uh it's very irksome right there you you
know this you know people who can't take
a compliment
and it's actually not a good trait you
should be able to take a compliment
graciously and then move on it's only
when people are really really obsessed
with themselves they're constantly
focusing on themselves
that they either harp on it for a really
long time
or they refuse the compliment and in so
doing also harp on it for a really long
time just
thank you just accept it it's fine joe
biden does not believe
that men that women rather are better
than men
joe biden does not trust women to do
men's jobs
joe biden does not trust women even to
be
women he wants men to be
women dr rachel levine
a biden appointee to be the
assistant secretary for health at
hhs was just confirmed
by the senate despite rachel's name
rachel is a man who identifies as a
woman
and he has become the first openly
transgender
federal official confirmed by the senate
and i will
say this because i you know obviously i
don't bear any ill will toward
this guy but the the whole issue is a
little
uh not quite right so i'll just i'll
just
describe to you what happened in the
most clinical
basic terms i can in our country
in our government a man
who thinks that he is a woman has become
one of the leaders of the department of
health
that is a monty python sketch that act
that actually
is a monty python sketch if you've ever
watched the life of brian you will see
this
gender issue come into stark light
why are you always on about women stan
i want to be one
what i want to be a woman
from now on i want you all to call me
loretta
what it's my right as a man
oh why'd you want to be loretta stan
i want to have babies want to have
babies it's every man's right to have
babies if he wants them
but you can't have babies don't you
oppress me
i'm not pressing you stand you i've got
a womb
where's the fetus gonna just take you're
gonna keep it in a box
here i've got an idea suppose you agree
that he can't actually have babies
not having a womb which is nobody's
fault not even the romans
but that he can have the right to have
babies
good idea judith we shall fight the
oppressors for your right to have babies
brother
sister sorry what's the point
what what's the point of finding dries
right to have babies when he can't have
babies
it is symbolic of our struggle against
oppression
it is like i'm watching a documentary it
is like i am
watching an actual news report of of our
culture right now and
monty python is making such an important
point in here
not even just about the the ridiculous
idea that a man can become a woman
but about the the language that we use
to describe our rights i mean this
appointment of a man who thinks he's a
woman to be one of the leaders of our
health department
is being hailed as a great
victory for rights the rights of of
people who
some people actually suffer from this
psychological condition where
they think that they're the opposite sex
or they very much desire to be the
opposite sex and some people are just
kind of doing it because it's
fashionable now
but this is being hailed as a big win
for the rights what right you can't have
a right to something that is not
possible logically you can't
but we talk about it this way we say he
has a right
to be a woman he can't be a woman it's
not
possible it's in the nature of what it
is to be a man
and what it is to be a woman the man
cannot be a woman
it's like saying the square has a right
to be a circle
the square cannot be a circle but it has
a right it's unfair that the square
cannot be a circle if the square wants
to be a circle well i don't think it's
unfair
because it is in the square's nature to
be a square but even in this fallen
world of ours
if we all acknowledge that you know
maybe the square really wants to be a
circle and we like the square and we
we want to make the square feel better
because the square is crying like the
guy in monty python
we still can't do it and we can defend
the abstract right
of the square to be a circle and we can
even
call the square a circle but that won't
change anything
the square will remain a square and
there is this
hubris this pride at the basis of
progressivism broadly which says that
we can transform the whole world
we can do whatever we want even if our
desires are not
in order with reality
the the old constitutional order in our
country
says that there are fixed laws and
eternal nature and eternal nature
and these fundamental realities and
we're going to have government in
accordance with that
progressivism explicitly states you can
read wilson
progressivism says we don't live in that
world anymore nothing's fixed
everything's evolving everything's
changing
we can do whatever we want whitaker
chambers writes about this beautifully
in witness which is uh whitaker chambers
is this ex-communist
who whose book helped turn reagan into a
conservative
and he said communism we might now
zoom it out a little bit and say
radicalism more broadly is
a lot of people think that it's a new
ideology it's not it's the
it's the alternative faith of mankind
it's it's as old as the garden of eden
it began in the garden of eden when the
the serpent told
adam and eve ye shall be as gods
that is the premise here
but ye shan't be ye shan't be as gods
you know uh chuck schumer on this whole
point he says the arc of history is long
but it keeps bending toward justice and
transgender americans you know deserve
this and it's so important and so
wonderful
that they're seeing this transgender
person and it's breaking down barriers
of ignorance
and fear the only ignorance here that is
being propagated is being propagated
like people
by people like chuck schumer and people
who are insisting
contrary to reality nature
and reason that
a man can be a woman or has some right
to be or that we all have some right
to things that are simply not possible
that are simply
incoherent don't let them get away
with that ignorance it will not it will
not breed the happiness and compassion
and
wonder that we all think it's going to
breed because it is not
possible we actually shall not be as
gods
we actually will not struggle as we
might sin as we might
we will not change the the fabric of
reality
and the more we try to do that the more
misery we're going to breed
one thing you can change though is your
diet and you can
you can change your appearance in a
little bit if you want to lose some
weight one way i really recommend doing
that
is nutrisystem nutrasystem is simple and
convenient with delicious meals
delivered
right to your door with little to no
meal prep required that means
no shopping in busy grocery stores that
means that with nutrasystem
you can lose up to 18 pounds in your
first two months
which is very important for me moving to
nashville you know it's uh
they have a lot of good like fried
chicken and biscuits here the plant is
clinically proven to put your body in
fat burning mode and helps you achieve
safe and healthy weight loss nutrasystem
helps you lose weight and learn how to
keep it off
they have a top rated app called nume
for
extra motivation to help you stay on
track you get unlimited one-on-one
coaching
i really recommend this stuff a lot of
my friends do weird fad crash diets
it that just doesn't work guys it works
for a little bit and then it falls apart
if you if you want to get in shape if
you want to lose weight do it a healthy
way do it a sustainable way
a nutrisystem great way to do that order
nutrisystem now go to nutrasystem.com
knowles to get 50 percent off
nutrasystem.com
knowles this sexual insanity by which we
now have
a leader of the department of health
as a man who thinks that he's a woman
that this this madness
has has reached down all the way to the
elementary schools it's not just a thing
that happens in elite halls of left
left-wing politics or in the university
say
it's going down to elementary schools
nebraska's
department of education has new health
standards
that would teach kindergartners
about sexual gender identity i'm sorry i
can't say sexual identity
gender identity fifth graders then are
introduced to the gender
spectrum which explains to
students that there are an infinite
number of gender identities
teachers then are encouraged to explain
that gender expression and gender
identity exist along
a spectrum and then when you get to
sixth grade then you really get this
kind of
sexual ideology where 11 year olds are
taught the
specific difference between being
cisgender transgender
gender non-binary gender expansive that
one seems kind of redundant doesn't it
and gender identity
five-year-olds to 11 year olds being
taught all of this stuff
and for the left-wingers who want to
mainstream it it's very smart if you
want to mainstream things teach it to
kids
all right kids are very impressionable
very formative
they are not yet educated so the less
educated they are the easier it will be
to implant ridiculous ideas like this
and what does the right do we complain
about it and
sometimes not even we don't even always
complain some squishes go along with it
out of a misplaced sense of compassion
but then are we willing to exercise
political power when we get it
when we actually get political power are
we willing to go into the schools and
say
nope not only are we also going to teach
our views maybe please
we are going to kick out all of your
insane views
we are going to ban them we are going to
use the force of the state
to exclude your insane radicalism
that undermines human flourishing in our
entire country
are we willing to do that no i think a
lot of republicans and conservatives say
ah it's a little i don't want to make
the
substantive claim i just want to talk
about you know free speech or academic
freedom or all these abstract
notions that have very very little to do
with the
practical tradition of free speech in
america and the practical
real conservative tradition in in the
west
that's the only way we're going to get
anywhere this is the thesis of my book
which is coming out speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which you can pre-order now for now i
don't know how much longer you'll be
able to
it's doing very well in pre-sales by the
way so thank you very much to those
who've pre-ordered it
this is my thesis and it shouldn't i
don't think it's a controversial thesis
it certainly shouldn't be
but i guess it is today it is a
controversial thesis
that republicans should make substantive
claims about the world
and then actually exercise political
power i would say that most
of the prominent conservatives of the
last
20 years at least have explicitly
disavowed that notion and that's why
they lose
lose lose lose
you know while conservatives go squishy
believe it or not there are actually
some democrats who are realizing that
this this stuff is crazy
that that's that especially the gender
ideology because it's the most insane
example of it
that really maybe we shouldn't be
teaching this to kids it's coming from
segments of the democratic party that do
not necessarily lead that party
a democratic representative cesar
mcknight
made this point on tucker's show the
other day
south carolina democrat legislator who
said these
these crazy radical democrats were
leading the party
they don't understand that
black and latino conser democrats
are not down with all this stuff when i
hear people suggest to me
that i'm a homophobe i resent that i
don't hate anyone
what i'm about is protecting children
and i think that in south carolina you
have to be 18 years old to get a tattoo
so how is it that you can get an
irrevocable
procedure performed on you at any age
during your adolescence it's ridiculous
so that's
what he is describing there is a totally
mainstream
argument it's an obvious argument we
have age of consent laws we say if
you're 17 or 16 you you can't consent to
have sex
but if you're six you can consent to
have your body mutilated and pumped full
of hormones
how is that possible take away the sec
the sexual aspect of it for a second
just just focus on the consent the whole
idea of consent here is that children
do not have the capacity to fully
consent to something
that's why he brings up this issue of
the tattoo
so who are democrats not getting it no
only some democrats are not getting it
because they don't understand that there
is a bit of a cultural divide here
between the white progressives who run
the party and the black and hispanic
democrats
who make up a lot of the voters one
thing that i think my party needs to
understand
is african-american democrats are very
much more conservative
than their than their white caucasian
counterparts they need to understand
that
they do need to understand that that is
obviously
true i i also
not to plug my book a second time my
book speechless but i talk about this a
little bit in the book too which is
when you pull people's views on
political correctness or now you might
say wokism or whatever all these radical
ideologies
you find that the only group
that that really approves of this stuff
white progressives progressive activists
who are
overwhelmingly white they are
whiter than the newly driven snow that
when you get down into some different
racial groups of different geographic
groups
that support breaks down now
you might ask well okay if if black
democrats are not on board
with this insane ideology that's running
the party why are they still democrats i
don't know my friend candace owens
obviously
started a whole organization to try to
convince black voters to leave the
democrat
party there are other organizations for
other identity
groups that are currently in the
democrat coalition that that people
think ought to leave the democrat
coalition
if they disagree on issues like this
sure
sure make i hope that happens but i
guess there's some lag time and
you know trump made a lot of inroads
among among minority voters but
not not enough to to really make a huge
difference
but make no mistake this radical
ideology is being driven
by white progressives who in so doing or
cultivating
a false sense of victimhood none more so
than megan rapino do you megan rappino
is a lady she's a soccer player i guess
and she has silly colored hair and she's
very
very left-wing megan rapino was just
speaking at the white house
and she as she's speaking there right
she's a fairly well-known person she's
fairly rich
she's speaking at the white house she
just had to complain
i'm a member of the lgbtq community
with pink hair and where i come from i
could have only dreamed that i would be
standing in the position i am today at
the white house
excuse me hold on she just said hi i'm a
lesbian and i've got silly
colored hair and i'm a liberal activist
uh
not totally surprising and i could have
only dreamed that i'd be here what are
you talking about
the dominant regime is explicitly
telling us
women are better than men the presidents
that women are better than men we're
told that
straight white men are the the bane of
ex of
all existence you know they're the
they're the source of evil in the world
we're told that uh unusual sexual
desires are much better than
straight sexual desires you're you are
the exact person
who would be standing there at the white
house she goes on to complain even more
i'm also a professional athlete and i've
helped
along with all of my teammates virtually
here
today one teammate literally here today
uh win four world cup championships
and four olympic gold medals for the
united states
and despite those wins i've been
devalued
i've been disrespected and dismissed
because i am a woman
and i've been told that i don't deserve
any more than less
because i am a woman
you see despite all the wins i'm still
paid less than men who do the same job
that i do
for each trophy of which there are many
and for each win for each tie and for
each time that we play
it's less and i know there are millions
of people who
are marginalized by gender in the world
and experience the same thing in their
jobs and i know that there are people
who experience
even more where the layers of
discrimination
continue to stack against them so
nothing she just said is true she's not
paid less for doing the same job she
does a different job she doesn't play
men's soccer if she played men's soccer
she would have never made it onto a high
school team because men are better
athletes than women because they're
bigger and stronger and faster
and that's just a fact of nature and you
can't change that nature
she's never been devalued she's
extraordinarily overvalued the president
of the united states
is standing there listening to this
woman babble on and complain
she's rich she's famous specifically for
her identity politics
and yet she brags and boasts and i've
got all these trophies
ugly ugly pride and then whines and
complains even more
ugly pride and a sort of a a false sense
of victimhood
how on earth anybody would would
associate themselves
with political views that this sort of
woman is preaching but she knows
that that victimhood has currency and i
think that is the sort of
cynical reason that a lot of people go
along with it is they know that if they
can
claim any sort of grievance any sort of
victimhood no matter how ridiculous like
this woman's
then they can get a certain advantage in
the society very
very ugly stuff if you
want to remain safe in these crazy times
you ought to check out ring that's what
i would do
so much is going on at our front doors
these days that is one thing that for
sure has not changed especially for me
with my cute little bundle of joy
little june who is getting you know
we're getting food delivered oh that's
great you know we're getting little
little baby clothes oh yeah open that
door right up give me those baby clothes
and we're getting uh in-laws visiting
well hold on
maybe then you don't want to i don't
know maybe you'll open the door maybe
you won't with ring
you can make that decision from inside
before you open the door whether you are
in your office maybe you are in your
bedroom maybe you're
on a beach on the other side of the
world with ring you can see and speak to
whoever
is on the other side of that door makes
me feel really safe
when i travel knowing that sweet little
elisa and cute little june do not need
to open the door
before they before they find out who is
outside of it that's a great
housewarming gift i
i give it to my friends unfortunately my
friends have realized
that i talk about this on the show and i
mentioned that you know i don't pay a
lot of money because ring is very
very well priced still makes a fabulous
fabulous
gift even even when they find out what a
great deal it is right now i got a
special offer on the ring welcome kid at
ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 and chime pro the perfect way to
upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience go to
ring.com knowles that is ring.com
knowles by the way if you want to check
out ben's
show you know sometimes i talk about
here
what ben is going to be talking about
later on on his show or on the radio
well look no further i'm going to be
hosting ben's show later today we got
a lot of brand new stuff things we're
not going to be able to get to on this
show today so go
go check out that out if you just miss
me too much when this show ends
also candace owens has a brand new talk
show with us exclusively at
dailywire.com
and if after listening to my show today
and if after listening to me on ben's
show
today you still you feel i need more
michael i haven't had enough michael
well you can head on over to candace's
show tomorrow i'm very excited to be on
candace's show
we shot it yesterday it's going to air
tomorrow it was a lot of fun i was there
with brandon tatum and bryce and gray
candace also has a podcast you can
listen to on apple you know on
apple spotify stitcher all the places
you get your podcasts jumped up to the
top of the charts
so go check that out if you want to
watch the full show you got to do that
it's only for daily wire members
but you can listen to clips over on on
the podcast
we'll be right back with a lot more
what is it with these megans claiming
victimhood
these rich famous megans
megan rapino the soccer lady meghan
markle the former
duchess lady what what is it with these
with these megans megan rapino claiming
because i am a lesbian and therefore i'm
at a great disadvantage in society is
that so i don't think that's true in our
politically correct culture
speaking though of lesbians and
victimhood
big news out of a public poll firm
public religion research institute
a poll that was just released on tuesday
for the first time
ever a majority of republican voters
have indicated that they support
same-sex marriage
for the first time a slim majority 51
percent say that
allowing gay and lesbian couples to
legally marry
and we'll get to that in a second it's
very poor wording on the question
is perfectly fine by them this is up
from 47 support
in 2019 uh independents
are also at a new high point 72
support up from the mid 60s in the past
few years more than three and four
democrats support
same-sex marriage up from 70 2019
similar uh to 77 percent in
2018 okay what's the issue here one i
don't think the marriage debate
is about rights
and i don't think it's about compassion
and i don't think it's about antipathy
toward people because of their sexual
desires
it's simply about reality it's about
what
is the the marriage debate
was framed by radical activists
as a question of who has the right to
get married well if it's a question of
rights then everyone should have the
right to get married
so therefore okay good we've now
redefined marriage to include same-sex
unions right
no because that was never that was never
the debate
if that were the debate then we would
have legalized polygamy with the same
supreme court case
because if everyone has the right to get
married and it's just a matter of rights
why can't three or four or five people
do it
why can't we call a whole town a
marriage because that's not what a
marriage is
the question of the marriage debate was
always
what is marriage
for all of human history everywhere
on planet earth sexual difference
was always thought to be essential to
marriage
and maybe in some times in some cultures
there was polygamy
but sexual difference was always at the
heart of marriage
the union of husbands and wives
men and women made complementary to one
another
with the logical possibility
of procreation the basic
fundamental and political institution of
the family
propagating the species living together
in harmony
then according to that
view of things there's no question of
who has the right to get married because
men and women have the right to get
married to one another because that's
what it means
in recent years not that long ago don't
forget barack obama running for
re-election
did not support gay marriage did not
support redefining marriage joe biden
actually kind of jumped him on the issue
but even in 2010 2011 barack obama
still said no it's ridiculous marriage
is a sacred union between a man and a
woman hillary clinton said the same
thing
but there was this new idea that sexual
difference has nothing to do with
marriage
okay well if that's the case then all
i'm asking you is
what is marriage what is it
well it's uh you know two people who
love each other okay well i love a lot
of people love my friends i love my
family
is that marriage no it's different it's
romantic love okay well i love my
boyfriend i love my girlfriend
so is that marriage no well it's no it's
different
michael you love your boyfriend shh i'm
not supposed to admit these things on
the show
we all date people right you know
why what is different about marriage
marriage
is when you make a commitment to a
specific
institution that will involve the
creation of family
so if if we can acknowledge that then we
can move past this crazy
crazy victimhood culture
but we can't do that because now even
the conservatives are losing sight of
what the actual argument is
has nothing to do with antipathy or
saying i don't like gay people or i
don't like this i don't like that it has
nothing to do with good intentions the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
the rest of the world by the way thinks
we're completely losing our minds
mexican president andres manuel lopez
obrador
he has come out and said
that joe biden in the united states are
to blame
for the migrant crisis at the border
take a listen
i'll read the subtitles expectations
were created that the government of
president biden
there would be a better treatment of
migrants
and this has caused central american
migrants and also from our country
wanting to cross the border thinking
that it is easier to do so
okay i think that's true i do think that
those
expectations were created and
now the mexican president is saying it's
an issue on our side too because you've
got all these people now coming up from
guatemala coming up from nicaragua
coming up from
el salvador who are
creating a lot of issues in our country
biden why won't you just enforce the law
well because
we have good intentions compassion we
need to let people in
the situation that's going on right now
is much worse it's not compassionate
it's very cruel
the rest of the world though looking at
us like we're completely insane
the student government right now at ucla
has just passed legislation
not not to say that uh okay we're going
to allow
illegal aliens to come to our school
not to say we're going to allow illegal
aliens to to mention that they are
illegal aliens and we're going to try to
not
not have them be prosecuted for it the
student government of ucla
just unanimously passed a 23 000
fund to give illegal aliens in this
country
a stipend to pay
foreign nationals to
be in this country and to serve on this
student government
the undocu council member stipend on
march 2nd
was was passed this according to the
college
fix this is not just a perversion of
standards this is an
inversion of standards right this is not
just saying
the old standards we're going to kick
you out of this country if you're not
supposed to be here
it's not just saying okay we're going to
let you stay it's saying we're going to
we're going to pay you to be here
we're going to give you our money and
money that can go to american students
at a public university we're going to
give it to foreign nationals
violating our laws that's how much we
hate ourselves in this country
that we please take our money
please violate our laws oh yes we
deserve it
this is true not just in these crazy
universities
this is true in cities around the
country the mayor of charlottesville
virginia
democratic mayor mayor nikuya walker
tweeted a bizarre and vulgar poem
wednesday
comparing her city the city that she is
supposed to lead
to a rapist poem
i'll read you the poem maybe this would
be my good snap poetry sort of you know
the beautiful ugly it is it lynched you
hung
the noose at city hall and pressed the
souvenir that was once
your finger against its lips it covers
your death with its good intentions it
is a place where white women with black
kids collects
collects signature for a white man who
questions whether a black woman
understands white supremacy huh what's
going on
it is destructively world-class
destructively world-class
white people say that it is a place
where gentrification started with the
election of a black woman in 2017
and because of white power a lie becomes
facts
its daily practice is that of separating
you from your soul
this is the city that she's the mayor of
charlottesville is a void of a moral
is void of a moral compass it's as if
good old thomas jefferson is still
cleverly using his whip to whip the
current inhabitants
into submissiveness charlottesville
rapes you of your breaths
it suffocates you of your hopes and
dreams oh gosh lady this place sounds
terrible i won't i won't finish it
you can read the the rest of the poem if
you want she says you know the city's
rooted in white supremacy and racism and
all that kind of stuff
she probably shouldn't be the mayor of
this town right
if you if you don't love your
town you probably shouldn't be in
service of your town right you
you probably shouldn't lead your town if
you hate it
if you hate your country you probably
shouldn't lead your country
in a way this is a form of false modesty
too because this woman is not saying i'm
bad she's not saying i
i have problems and i am contributing to
the problems in this community
she's saying everybody else is
every other ev every problem in the
whole world is someone else's fault
but it's never heard so she says you
know it's this town that i'm the leader
of it's really
terrible and bad but not me i'm the good
one you know but but
everyone's really terrible here it's a
great true form of pride it's completely
tone deaf to the realities of of human
brokenness and original sin
but this is also a form of filial
impiety the reason we
we ought to love our countries the
reason it's right and just to love your
country and be
a patriot is because of filial piety
it's an extension
of the natural obligation you have of
loyalty
duty and even love for your family and
then you extend that more broadly
and you get up to the nation and beyond
the nation for that matter
this is a form of filial impact it's
very ugly even people who live in not
great countries when they just turn
on their country it's ugly just like if
you hear someone bad-mouthing his family
or bad-mouthing his community it's just
ugly even if some criticism is warranted
you think this kind of disdain this
contempt is really really
wrong stuff
we're actually beginning to see this
among conservatives too so really i'm
sorry to report this
because i had high hopes for christy
gnome the governor of south dakota
i suppose i still have high hopes for
her she hasn't been in the spotlight all
that long
so i hope she she writes the ship right
now because she's really going in the
wrong direction
christy gnome caved to special interests
on the question of women's
sports on this gender question i guess
should be a very simple question for a
conservative
and she refused to sign legislation that
would ban
men from competing in women's sports and
she said no
maybe you know we need to let we need to
make the legislation stronger by
weakening it you know and we need to let
men compete in women's sports or
something and she obviously got bullied
by special interests
and she betrayed a very basic
conservative view
so conservatives from across the board
have criticized her for this
and now she's punching back at the
conservatives
at least her spokesman is her spokesman
ian fury said
governor gnome is very used to fighting
off criticism from the left
after all in the past years she was the
only governor in the entire nation to
never order a single business or church
in her state to close yes she did a
great job
she was bullied by the left but she
didn't cave yep true
but if any number of conservative
pundits are to be believed that same
governor who refused to cave
is now caving to the ncaa and amazon on
the issue of fairness in women's sports
yes that's true that's what she's doing
what apparently uninformed cancer
culture is fine
when the right is eating their own oh
bad move lady bad move ian fury
you think that so you make a big mistake
and you betray your
your base and your constituents on a
very simple question and that's bad
enough you can still just admit you were
wrong and right the ship but instead now
you start attacking conservatives and
you call them uninformed
and say that it's cancelled culture
first of all as i've said from the
beginning of
of cancel culture the phrase is sort of
unhelpful in that
it's describing a real phenomenon which
is that the libs
are are destroying people's livelihoods
for saying ordinary and right and true
things
but this doesn't mean that we should
never criticize people it doesn't mean
that we shouldn't have standards and
frankly it doesn't mean that we
shouldn't
ostracize or even censor some forms of
speech
we had a cancel culture sort of in the
1950s
when when senator mccarthy and the house
committee and un-american activities
and patriots in hollywood were
booting communists out of our
institutions of government and culture
and when we were booting soviet spies
out of the federal government
like alger his and harry dexter white
yeah that was good
i'm glad that we were doing that and
criticizing all of our politicians
and holding their feet to the fire is a
good thing notice nowhere in this
in this diatribe from from gnome's
spokesman does
he ever attempt to refute the point
which is which is so obvious as right
before our very eyes
gnome refused to sign the legislation
that would have said that men are men
and women are women and the men
shouldn't compete in women's sports
and it's a logical conclusion seems
common sense to me
that it's not because her constituents
bullied her into that she betrayed her
constituents here it's because some
special interests bullied her into it
okay just say you're sorry and change
your mind or defend
the bad decision not to sign the
legislation but don't call me uninformed
if you're going to call me that at least
refute the argument
but they can't refute the argument you
can't refute the argument
at all not a good look to turn on your
own guys
especially as as 2024 heats up
there is going to be as president trump
said a very deep bench in 2024 among
people who want to run for president
and who i think would be good candidates
lots of governors
lots of senators lots of sharp people
lots of
of really tough conservative politicians
if if you
can't handle some perfectly legitimate
tame frankly criticism from
some political commentators on your own
side
how on earth do you think conservatives
are going to trust you
to be their nominee and run for
president
there's a lot of time before 2024 but
people got to shape up people got to get
ready for prime time
very sad to see that that christine is
going down this wrong path
in in south dakota turning on her
conservatives sort of
the spokesman lashing out at them
meanwhile though another governor and
potential 2024 nominee is playing his
cards perfectly that would be
ron desantis down in florida the guy has
has really done great on kovid
and he's now trying to parlay that into
a broader sort of platform
can he do that i don't know you know we
don't know a lot about the guy
so we'll see how far he can go so far
he's doing a great job
he also is doing a great job of of
handling the media
so a reporter at a recent press
conference accused governor desantis
of bungling the covid response and
desantis he channeled his inner
newt gingrich he channeled his inner
trump and went after the reporter
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publix we can do this they
calculated that 90
of their seniors live within a mile and
a half of a publix
and they said we think that would be the
easiest thing for our residents
so we did that and what ended up
happening was you had 65 publics in palm
beach
palm beach is one of the biggest
counties one of the most elderly
counties
we've done almost 75 percent of the
seniors in palm beach and the reason is
because you have the strong retail
footprint
so our uh whey has been multi-faceted it
has worked
and we're also now very much expanding
cvs and walgreens
now that they've completed the long-term
care mission yes
and it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative i just disabused you of the
narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not
no no no you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong yes sir
no no you're wrong i love that it's not
enough
just to refute the narrative you you've
also got to
tell people that you've refuted the
narrative that that is how strong the
the democratic
and leftist communications apparatus is
you gotta spike the football sometimes
and uh desantis knows how to do that
he's very good at
uh the political theater so strong stuff
i mean it's really good
i think he'll have a good shot you know
i've made no secret of the fact that
i'm very in favor of senator cruz
running
in 2024. i don't i don't have any inside
knowledge or and you know i'm not
uh i i haven't heard anything despite
pestering him on the set of our verdict
show to say hey are you going to run are
you going to run
i really don't know but i would
encourage him to run i think he would
certainly be part of that
deep bench of conservatives who would be
really strong president trump agrees he
said the same thing the other day
and uh and senator cruz proved it again
similar kind of exchange uh this i think
even more
important frankly he was giving a press
conference
and a reporter asked him
why he wasn't wearing his mask at the
press conference and uh
senator cruz i think handled it
perfectly
uh yeah when i'm talking to the tv
camera i'm not gonna wear a mask and all
of us have been immunized
so you make us feel better you're
welcome to
step away if you like
the whole point of a vaccine cdc
guidance
is what we're following yeah i love it
oh sir excuse me will you need to put
the mask on uh no
no because i'm speaking you know and i'm
on tv
and uh and also by the way i've been
immunized well no but we just we would
rather
you put the mask on yet no you can step
away if you want that's fine i'm not
going to stop you from
frankly i'd prefer it if you would step
away thank you but no i'm you're not
going to have me
muzzle myself a minute longer than i
have to
we follow the science a great answer is
really
really good stuff and and i i really
hope that every other republican takes
note here
i really hope so because uh
that's the only way that we're gonna
push back is by actually taking off the
stupid mask
and actually not letting these people
bully us
offering substantive arguments a great
substantive argument just came out of
utah
got to get to utah's governor spencer
cox who signed a piece of legislation on
tuesday
requiring all smartphones and tablets
sold in utah to have filters that can
block pornography
now the way this will be implemented it
will take effect
on the first day of january next year or
i'm sorry on the next
the first day of january following the
day when at least
five other states put forth similar laws
and those laws take effect themselves so
the reason for this is it would be very
difficult to implement
if the phone companies have to only do
this for one state
probably you couldn't actually get it
done but if you have multiple states
doing it'd be much much easier to get
the
phone companies to do it this is a great
idea i know that some people from the
squish wing of the republican party are
going to say oh no
no the george washington fought the
revolution so that everyone has a right
to look at a lot of weird porn on their
phone
but it just isn't true and uh for all of
our country's history we've had laws
against obscenity
and they've often were enforced pretty
pretty stringently in recent days
they haven't been enforced as much but
you know even as recently as 2008 i
think it was
george w bush jailed a pornographer
simply for obscenity
so this is perfectly fine i need to show
an id to go buy a playboy
you know down down the street at the cd
magazine store
but i can look at anything i want on my
phone anywhere not not just me i'm an
adult what about a kid
not not to sound like the lady from the
simpsons but won't somebody please think
of the children
seriously this is this is a point that
drives me crazy i can't tell you how
many
letters i get in the mail bag and even
people sending things on twitter
of young men who say that their lives
have been really really
harmed by porn by being exposed to porn
and getting hooked on it when they're
really young
and it's it's amazing because the
left-wing culture tells young men
you me these toxic men they need to go
to therapy they need to talk about their
feelings they need to tell us what
they're they're really
what's going on inside and then the
young men do tell you and they say yeah
we've got this
horrible porn culture that's driving us
all completely insane and we need some
limits on it
largely i've noticed young men who are
pushing to regulate porn or ban
porn yeah because they're the ones who
are being affected by it
and then the minute that the the men say
their feelings the left says oh you're a
prude you're ridiculous you're a fascist
you're a nazi shut up
you vile bigot or something well no
let's how about we
follow the first part of the less logic
let's take this seriously
the founding fathers and every serious
person who's ever governed our country
would love this sort of legislation
which says
that we're not going to encourage
licentiousness
because licentiousness destroys liberty
we have this modern idea that
licentiousness and liberty the same
thing they're not
they're not they're they're actually
polar opposites
and for the i mean this this legislation
this took serious
to use the italian phrase a strong spine
let's say
for this governor of utah to sign it i
wish the legislation were a little
stronger
uh but this this is a good start of
republicans offering a substantive
vision
for our country i'm michael moses the
michael show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt wall show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show